COUNTRIES FORMERLY OCCUPIED BY
THE RUSSIANS.
COULD UKRAINE SOON JOIN THAT
LIST?
JOHN AVLON WITH A REALITY CHECK.
>> ANY ILLUSIONS THAT VLADIMIR
PUTIN IS A MASTER STRATEGIST
SUFFERED ANOTHER BLOW YESTERDAY.
WHEN THE LEADER OF SWEDEN AND
FINLAND ANNOUNCED THEY'RE MOVING
TOWARD JOINING NATO AFTER MORE
THAN 70 YEARS OF NEUTRALITY.
THAT'S RIGHT.
IT SEEMS THAT PUTIN HAS
SUCCEEDED IN CREATING THE THING
HE SAID HE FEARED THE MOST, THE
EXPANSION OF NATO.
BECAUSE, REMEMBER, THAT WAS THE
LOGIC HE TROTTED OUT TO
INITIALLY EXPLAIN THE INVASION
OF UKRAINE.
YES, PUTIN AND HIS APOLOGISTS
SAID OVER AND OVER AGAIN THAT
NATO, BY EXTENSION AMERICA, HAD
CREATED THIS CRISIS.
SO LET'S PUT ASIDE THE FACT THAT
NO ONE SERIOUSLY THOUGHT UKRAINE
WAS ABOUT TO JOIN NATO.
THIS WAS ALWAYS AN EXCUSE,
RIGHT?
AN OPPORTUNISTIC ANXIETY NOT
ROOTED IN REALITY, BUT IT TURNED
INTO A BLOODY VERSION OF BLAMING
THE VICTIM.
NATO IS A DEFENSIVE ALLIANCE,
FOUNDED BY THE U.S. AND ALLIES
AFTER THE SECOND WORLD WAR TO
ACT AS A COLLECTIVE BULWARK
AGAINST SOVIET EXPANSION.
HISTORY SHOWS REALLY CLEARLY WHY
RUSSIANS WESTERN NEIGHBORS ARE
THE ONES WHO HAVE GOOD REASON TO
FEAR RUSSIAN AGGRESSION AND NOT
REMOTELY THE OTHER WAY AROUND.
I'LL SPARE YOU THE STORY OF
RUSSIA'S PARTITION OF POLAND OR
THE ATTEMPT TO TAKE WARSAW IN
1920, LET'S START WITH THE
SECOND WORLD WAR, OKAY.
IN 1939, DURING THE
NONAGGRESSION PACT WITH HITLER,
THE SOVIETS TRIED TO INVADE,
LIBERATE FINLAND.
AND FAILED, DESPITE HAVING
LARGER FORCES.
1940, USSR INVADED THE BALTIC
STATES.
1945, STALIN TOOK FREE AND FAIR
ELECTIONS, BUT HE SAID ABOUT
DOING THE OPPOSITE AND
ESTABLISHING WHAT WINSTON
CHURCHILL CALLED THE IRON
CURTAIN.
IN QUICK SUCCESSION, STALIN TOOK
CONTROL OF ALBANIA, POLAND,
ROMANIA AND CLAIMED EAST GERMANY
AS ITS OWN.
THE SOVIETS SEND IN TANKS AND
CRUSHED A REBELLION.
IN 1968, THE LEADER OF
CZECHOSLOVAKIA BEGAN
LIBERALIZING THE SOVIET TANKS
AGAIN RUTHLESSLY ROLLED IN.
SOVIET EXPANSION WAS THE PATTERN
UNTIL THE FALL OF THE USSR, WHAT
PUTIN CALLED THE GREATEST
GEOPOLITICAL CATASTROPHE FOR THE
20th CENTURY.
YOU KNOW WHO DIDN'T THINK IT WAS
A CATASTROPHE?
THOSE COUNTRIES THAT HAD BEEN
CO-OPTED BY THE SOVIETS FOR SO
LONG.
YOU KNOW WHAT THEY DID?
THEY ASKED TO JOIN NATO AS A
GUARANTEE OF THEIR SECURITY.
THERE WAS DEBATE HERE IN
OVERSEAS, GOOD PEOPLE CAN
DISAGREE, YOU CAN'T REALLY
QUESTION WHY POLAND, HUNGARY AND
CZECHOSLOVAKIA JOINED NATO IN
1999 OR 11 OTHER NATIONS OVER
THE NEXT TWO DECADES.
6% OF RUSSIA'S LAND BORDERS
TOUCH NATO COUNTRIES.
NOT EXACTLY EVIDENCE OF
ENCIRCLEMENT.
BUT RUSSIA'S OLD EXPANSIONIST
IMPULSE RETURNED WITH A
VENGEANCE UNDER PUTIN AND IN
NON-NATO NATIONS LIKE THE
INCURSION OF RUSSIA, GEORGIA,
WHICH PUTIN CLAIMED WAS ALL
ORCHESTRATED BY THE U.S. OR THE
2014 SEGREGATION OF CRIMEA FROM
UKRAINE, FOLLOWED BY YEARS OF
FUNDING FIGHTERS IN THE DONBAS
REGION.
IN BETWEEN THIS, POISONINGS ON
BRITISH SOIL, BANKING ASSAD IN
SYRIA, AND THE MURDER AND
JAILING OF OPPONENTS AT HOME.
THE INVASION OF UKRAINE WAS
FINALLY A BRIDGE TOO FAR.
AND THE WESTERN WORLD HAS
RALLIED AROUND THE RESISTANCE AS
A DEFENSIVE SOVEREIGNTY AND
DEMOCRACY.
SELF-STYLED STRONG MEN FEAR
LOOKING WEAK AND PUTIN'S EPIC
MISCALCULATION WILL NOT STOP HIM
FROM DOUBLING DOWN.
MORE EVIDENCE OF WAR CRIMES WILL
EMERGE IN THE COMING WEEKS NO
DOUBT.
AS WE CONFRONT THE HUMAN COST OF
THIS INVASION, WE'RE ALSO
CONFRONTING THE LEGACY OF
RUSSIAN EXPANSION AT THE HANDS
OF SOMEONE WHO HAS GOTTEN AWAY
WITH HIS LIES FOR TOO LONG.
SO LOOK AT THE FACTS OF HISTORY
AND DON'T BELIEVE THE HYPE.
NATO EXPANSION ISN'T TO BLAME